i'm grateful to sue gray for her report
today and i want to thank her for the
work that she's done
i also thank the metropolitan police for
completing their
investigation
and i want to begin today by renewing my
apology to the house to the whole
country
for
the short lunch time gathering on the
19th of june 2020 in the cabinet room
during which i stood at my place at the
cabinet table in which i received a fix
penalty notice and i also want to say mr
speaker above all that i take full
responsibility for everything that took
place on my watch
sue gray's report has emphasized that it
is up to the political leadership in
number 10 to take ultimate
responsibility
and of course i do
but since these investigations have now
come to an end this is my first
opportunity
to set out some of the context
and to explain both my understanding of
what happened and also to explain what
i've previously said uh to this house
and
it's it's important to set out
that
over a period of about 600 days
gatherings on a total of eight dates
have been found to be in breach of the
regulations in a building that is 5 300
meters square across five floors
excluding the flats
mr speaker i do think it is impossible
it is important because this is the
first time i've had a chance i've had to
set out the context
hundreds of staff are entitled to work
and in the cabinet office which has
thousands of officials and now is the
biggest it's been in any point in its
hundred year history that is in itself
one of the reasons why the government is
look now looking for change and reform
mr speaker those staff working in
downing street were permitted to
continue attending their office for the
purpose of work and the exemption under
the regulations applied to their work
because of the nature of their jobs
reporting directly to the prime minister
these people were working extremely long
hours
doing their best to give this country
the ability to fight the pandemic
during mr speaker i appreciate that this
is no uh mitigation but it is important
to set up prime minister please just
just one sec can it just appeal to the
house expect it to be heard and i want
everybody to hear it and i want the same
respect to be shown to the leader of the
opposition afterwards so please this is
a very very important statement the
country wants to hear as well prime
minister yeah mr speaker i'm trying to
set out the context not to uh not to to
mitigate or uh to absorb myself in any
way
the exemption under which they were
present in downing street uh includes
those circumstances where officials and
advisors were leaving the government
and it was
appropriate
to
recognize them to thank them for the
work that they've done
[Music]
let me let me come to that mr speaker i
briefly attended such gatherings to
thank them for their service
which i believe is one of the essential
duties of leadership and particularly
important
and particularly important when people
need to feel that their contributions
have been appreciated
and to keep morale as high as possible
i'm trying to explain the reasons i was
there mr speaker
and it's clear from what uh sue gray has
had to say
that some of these gatherings
then went on
far longer than was necessary
and they were clearly
in breach of the rules and they fell
foul of the rules
i have to tell the house because the
house will need to know this and again
this is not to mitigate or to extenuate
i had no knowledge of those subsequent
proceedings because i simply wasn't
there
and i have been as surprised and
disappointed
as anyone else in this house
as the revelations have unfolded
and frankly mr speaker i have been
appalled
by some of the behavior
particularly in the treatment of the
security and the cleaning staff
and i would like to apologize
to those members of staff
and i expect anyone who behaved in that
way to apologize to them as well
and
i'm happy to set on the record now
that when i said i came to this house
and said in all sincerity that the rules
and guidance have been followed
at all times it was what i believed to
be true
it was certainly the case
when i was present at gatherings to wish
staff farewell
and the house will note that my
attendance at these moments brief as it
was has not been found to be outside the
rules
but clearly this was not the case for
some of those gatherings after i have
left and at other gatherings when i was
not even in the building
so i would like to correct
i would like to correct the record uh to
take this opportunity
not in any sense to absolve myself of
responsibility
which i take and have always taken
but simply
simply to explain
why i spoke as i did in this house
mr speaker
in response to her interim
report sue gray acknowledges that very
significant changes have already been
enacted
she writes
and i quote
i am pleased that progress is being made
in addressing the issues i raised
and she adds
since my update there have been changes
to the organization and management of
downing street in the cabinet office
with the aim of creating clearer lines
of leadership and accountability and now
these need the chance and time to bed in
number 10 now has its own permanent
secretary charged with applying the
highest standards of governance there
are now easier ways for staff to voice
any worries
and
sue welcomes that sue grey welcomes that
i quote steps have since been taken
to introduce more easily accessible
means by which to raise concerns
electronically in person or online
including directly with the permanent
secretary
the entire senior management has changed
there is a new
there is a new
there is a new chief of staff
an elected member of this house who also
commands the status of a cabinet
minister
there is a new director of
communications a new principal private
secretary
and another of other key appointments
in
my office
i am confident with the changes and new
structures
that are now in place
that we are humbled
by the experience
and we have learned
our lesson
and i want to conclude
by saying that
i mr speaker i i'm humbled and i have
learned a lesson
and i want to go and i want to conclude
by saying that whatever the failings
whatever the failings of
yeah we'll come to that we'll come to
that
and whatever the failings of
number 10 and the cabinet office right
this very difficult period which on my
own which i take full responsibility
i continue to believe that the civil
servants and advisors in question
hundreds of them
thousands of them some of whom mr
speaker the very people who've received
fines
are good hard-working people
motivated motivated by the highest
calling to do the very best for our
country and i will always be proud of
what they achieved
including procuring essential
life-saving ppe creating the biggest
testing program in europe and helping to
enable the development and distribution
of the vaccine which got this country
through the worst pandemic of a century
and now mr speaker we must get our
country through the aftershocks of covid
with every ounce of ingenuity and
compassion and and hard work
so i hope that today as well as learning
the lessons from
the su grades report which i'm glad i
commissioned and again i repeat my i'm
glad i'm grateful to her i i hope very
much but now that she has reported
we will be able to move on and focus
on the on the priorities of the british
people
standing firm against russian aggression
easing the hardship caused by the rising
costs the people are facing fulfilling
our pledges to generate a high wage high
skill high employment economy that will
unite and level up across the whole of
our united kingdom that is my mission
that is our mission that is the mission
of the whole of the government and we
will work day and night to deliver it
and i commend this statement to the
house